it's late
i should head home
right-hand traffic
oh i'm on a bicycle hello everybody
welcome to burger and frights
um
all right uh
okay
i'm assuming i just got off my late
night i don't need to introduce anything
it does it all for me
ah nice
very nice
pretty intense
also kind of familiar wait a minute have
i played this before
i played a few burger related horror
games i have to shout because it's so
loud
have i played this before
hi what would happen if i died
[Music]
okay
oh we're good now
well
maybe this is just gonna be oh
that's a little weird considering it
looks just like my bike
but uh
okay
is that kind of the crux of this game
huh
maybe i died to a car crash and i just
don't know it's real dark
oh it's real dork hi what hello
hello don't hit me
what is that what the hell
what the hell
oh
what
it's late i should head mama
no
wait a minute this has this doesn't have
anything to do with burgers at all it's
not actually a burger-based game
it's based on me and my own death
also tuo nella whatever that means did i
like is this is this my actual nightmare
where i imagine that i've actually died
many times
[Music]
but every time i die just accidentally
hop over to an adjacent universe and i
continue living on as if i didn't just
get horribly mangled by a tar
hello again
hi okay weird
you're weird
hmm
well there's that oh blood this time oh
i love playing in blood puddles
oh hi
hello ma'am do you need help
ma'am
sir
person
fellow human hopefully
maybe
okay
um
well
it's late i should head homey okey-dokey
then
i'll just head on home
where are you taking me game
where's this carnival ride gonna go
what are you gonna do
to and or for
me what does tuo nella mean it's f
oh it's not oh it is there okay you are
there i really hope you're a scarecrow
not actually just a corpse hanging up on
the a stick there
that'd be a twist can i pop this bad boy
into turbo mode
what
[Music]
oh oh you it's you it's you
oh
sick beat dude
um
it's a little strange
your behavior is slightly erratic
but uh
okay
oh that's a lot more blood that's a lot
more blood than
this game has many more trumpets than an
other trumpet based game
what are you blaming me about why are
you hitting me with the blue
don't blame me bro
hello oh it's a train right of course
well i'll stop then
it's the only reasonable thing to do
ah
oh
what is that
what am i looking at lady dammit rescue
is that you oh no that's just a tree
that's a tree i thought it was
i knew it
oh hi
you're not lady d
can i help you
can you help me
okay don't don't help me don't help me i
don't actually want any help
you don't want any help either i'm
terrible at helping i'll just end up
hurting
[Music]
ah we love laughing
oh
boy
ah
well then i'll just
okay well that's the first time i've
been able to win
well i don't like this
oh god hi whipsies missed me by that
much no thank you
oh god oh god
okay
[Applause]
what is someone
what what are you doing in the woods
what is the splooshing whooshing sounds
i know it's supposed to be whispers but
it just sounds like someone's watching
oh god no
okay i'm fine apparently
no thank you
i mean so far so good i have to blink a
lot oh no this is the worst time ah my
eyes
oh they're betraying me
it's fine oh hey look it's
it's late i should
head home
i think hmm
the old burger joint ain't doing so good
you know no one ever said that home was
this way maybe home was the other way
but now i'm too stuck in my ways to
change i can't help myself
weird
oh where's the scarecrow
where's the scarecrow
i don't like that the scarecrow is not
there
it's comforting like an old friend
if you're gone
then that means it got you
and then it's gonna get me
oh my god
[Applause]
are you just riding on the back wheel
with your arms draped around my
shoulders are you
you oh man that was a guy that was good
i love hugs you hug me so good from
behind
your arms draped around my neck
holding me tight
i feel like i can't breathe
nice trick dude
he's sick
all right don't mind me i'm just gonna
cross over this and not get hit
kathunka
oh hey it's a 2-0
is this the tuna
i never made it to the tunnel before
oh this what was that what did i just
see there yeah whatever i thought i saw
something on the
fencer nah it's just the design of it
okay well better keep my eyes peeled
just in case oh god no oh my god no oh
no oh no no no oh no uh no no no no no
no
no no thank you no no i'm good thank you
i'm good thank you i appreciate it good
i am good i am good thank you
i'm good
help no it's behind me
don't you dare
oh hi again
oh that's not good
oh that's even worse
i thought it was not good from the
get-go what do i do pedal faster this is
where i would hit turbo mode this is
where i would kick it into overdrive
this is where uh
i shouldn't look back okay i gotta watch
out oh potholes yeah
okay how's that car following me still
well this bridge uh
this bridge has seen better days
just gonna say that straight up i don't
think the spread should be in one piece
but whatever
[Music]
we
everyone shut up i'm concentrating
you ever seen a pro gamer at work
this is what they call an mlg move
oh my god oh my god oh my god three
narrates oh max payne all over again
did i make it
i bet i won
this feels like i won
this feels like victory
oh good
it's me oh
i'll let you draw the connections in
your head
oh too oh nella it's actually a tunnel
now
not a bed
scarecrow
you there scarecrow you're back okay
you're back oh i don't like how slow i'm
going
okay scare chris beck that's good
oh hi oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
well where am i
i'm assuming that is me and i got hit by
a car and this is my last moments of my
brain dying and
all the horrors are just my
fleeting brain signals pumping furiously
clinging on to life
before death and darkness claims me this
is different
okay
oh good
oh oh that's not good
is there something behind me
this really feels like there's something
behind
this would be the moment where there's
something behind me oh yeah there's
something behind me all right
oh watch out for bicycles yeah you're no
kidding um
hey
all right
you know there's suspiciously less
burgers than i thought they were going
to be in this game
no that's not good
oh
no
it's my dream come true hey
okay i'll drive i'll drive i'll drive my
bicycle okay cool
you're supposed to yield the bicycles
lady
you're supposed to yield so uh could you
yield
oh god i'm supposed to yield to buy
cycles
oh god it's a bullet hell of bicycles
okay okay okay it's fine
you guys are so slow
eat my dust everyone else
you get swamped by the lady
not the worst fate if you ask me whoa
you don't ask me don't ask don't ever
ask me
all right you guys all right you guys
you're being a little silly here you're
getting a little silly a little
silliness going on here
a little too much silliness
ah hey stop it
hey cut it out
flawless flawless flawless too nella
oh god oh yeah oh yeah grabby hands
oh no thank you
no thanks no thanks no thanks
no thank you no thank you
[Music]
no thank you oh god
oh hi all right well
okay then where uh
uh
surprisingly skill based game
good thing i'm just so goddamn i'm gonna
shut up now and concentrate jesus
[Music]
this is my tryhard face
[Music]
oh well
looks like that's it for me then oh
i'm back
i'm oh
hey you okay there man
oh that's a thumpy base
what's going on over here
what's up pal oh
stop okay
i won't do that
[Music]
man it's getting really slurpy on the
base
i love it though it's too late oh
so i guess i don't go home then
so you're saying
i just i don't i don't bother
oh yeah
oh it's too late
okay all right oh hi hey what's up
council of elders how are you doing
are you judging my soul am i worthy
please say i'm worthy
[Music]
or don't say anything
[Music]
well
pretty out
i gotta give it that oh is this a sweet
ramp am i gonna ramp into the eyeball i
really hope so oh what is this
what am i looking at what am i looking
at
oh
um
oh
not that oh
what the hell
hi oh okay
yeah this is fair
i don't know what i've done to deserve
this but i bet it's fair come on give me
a big hug oh yeah oh yeah you gotta come
in that way it's the only way we'll fit
emma
give me give me big hug
oh
oh hi
[Music]
you do not belong okay
you sure i think i fit right in
i think i fit right in
yeah no you don't need to tell me twice
dive through i would do exactly the same
i would do exactly the same
wow
man what was in that burger
[Music]
do
[Music]
now that's a nice twist now that is a
nice twist hey
nice twist i love that i wasn't the bike
i was the person in the car i love that
that was fantastic that was great i
enjoyed that very much link is in the
description for that video there that
was very good i would call that incredi
good i think that was fantastic burger
and frights you're all right and hey
thank you everybody so much for watching
that was very very good i enjoyed that
incredibly
and you know what else you'll enjoy
distractible it's our podcast where we
have fun a lot of laughs and some
thoughtful discussions as well i know
you'll enjoy it check out the animation
of one of the few many many stories that
we've talked about right here on my
channel go to distractable through the
link in the description all right i'm
gonna go all right
love you
[Music]
you